الى خبر عن جريمه اخرى وهذه فعليا ما
ينقال عليها الا بئس الفلوس اللي تخلي
واحد يفاول على اولاده وكذا ففي الاردن تم
القبض على اب وابنه جبته بتهمه الاحتيال
على ثلاث شركات تامين بما مجموعهم مليون
و400 الف دينار اردني يعني تقريبا اثنين
مليون دولار الاحتيال كان بفبركه وفاه
البنت للحصول على ثلاثه بوليسات تامين
القصه انه الاب اللي بيشتغل في السياحه من
سنتين طلع على بنته اسمها البتول ثلاثه
بوليصات تامين على الحياه هذا عادي
الموضوع قانوني يعني وبعدين تفاجا الجيران
والاقارب بوفاه البنت بجلطان فتح عزا
وجنازه وشيخ بيدعي واندفنت البيت او
اندفنت البنت في مقابر وفي شاهد باسمها
كمان بعدين الاب كلف ثلاثه محاميين كل
واحد منهم انه يبدا يطالب شركه من الثلاثه
بوليس للتامين الشركات بدات زي العاده
انها تتحقق من كل التفاصيل قبل ما تصدر
قيمه البوليس قام اكتشفت واحده من الشركات
انه البنت كان عندها حاله طبيه مزمنه ما
اعل وقت ما طلعت البوليصه وهذا مخالف
للقانون فقالت انه خلينا نبحث اكثر في
القصه ولما بحثوا اكثر اكتشفوا ان البنت
في لها ثلاثه بوليسات تامين على الحياه
والثلاثه لصالح والدها تستغربوا او كذا
قالوا خلونا نبحث اكثر واكتشفوا اشياء
اغرب مثلا انه البنت توفت في مستشفى شهاده
الوفاه طالعه من مستشفى ثانيه هذا غير انه
تصريح الدفن طالع بعد اسبوع من الوفاء وما
في اي وثيقه تثبت انها دخلت ثلاجه موته في
اي مكان خلال هذه المده فراحت الشركات
بلغوا السلطات سلطات راحوا يتحروا قام
دقوا على باب بيت الاب قام فتحت لهم بنت
سالوها انت مين قالت لهم البتول وهنا
انكشفت القصه والسلطات امرت بنفس القبر
ويعرفوا مين اللي اندفن لقي جوا القبر
لعبه بلاستيك بحجم انسان كده مكفنه
السلطات اتحركت وانقبض على الاب والبنت
وسته اشخاص اخرين من اصل ثمانيه متورطين
معاهم واحد منهم هربان لسه التاني برا
البلد لانه
بيعمل عمره ما شاء الله عليه يعني اللهم
قوي فينا فعليا لا تعليق
[موسيقى]